[Music]
[Music]
I'm pleased to welcome to this platform
mr. Lee a Iacocca chairman of the board
of directors and chief executive officer
of the Chrysler Corporation mr. Iacocca
will now give the commencement address
Thank You dr. Saxon and good morning you
only been here about an hour and I've
all had a little little bit of pressure
put on me no less than six trustees have
reminded me that Winston Churchill spoke
to the commencement class 36 years ago
they said it was the biggest crowd that
they ever had at a commencement that he
gave his usual rousing speech but most
important the audience was upbeat and
enthusiastic you have to remember now
that he had one huge advantage over me
the Celtics were not down 2 to 1 in the
championship series that year but if
you'll just hang in there trust me
they're gonna win it in seven the hard
way but president gray members of the
MIT corporation members of the faculty
distinguished guests and parents and
members of the class of 1985 thank you
for asking me to share this very special
day with all of you and it is a special
day it's a day for all of you graduates
to thank your teachers for their hard
work and your parents for all their
sacrifices and by the way don't forget
to Pat yourselves on the back - you
deserve it and my hat is off to every
one of you I asked one of your alumni at
Chrysler to tell me a little bit about
MIT students he said quickly they're all
brilliant but they're too intense and
they're too competitive he said the only
thing they can't seem to learn is how to
relax well let me tell you relax today
it's your day enjoy it
relax but don't go to sleep because
tomorrow the real final exams start then
they'll go on for the rest of your lives
I'm going to try to give you a little
peek at the test but I won't be able to
help you with the answers they'll have
to come from you but in case you'll want
to take a nap for the next 20 minutes or
so
I'll give you the ending to this speech
right now
I'm gonna tell you to go out and change
the world that's my duty right that's
what every commencement speaker says and
every graduating class just sits there
hoping he'll be briefed so they cannot
go uncork the champagne but musing to
themselves if the world had to be
changed why in the hell didn't he do it
well
my generation tried pretty hard at times
and with some success I might add i sat
in your place and those happy days at
the end of World War two that was a good
war you know the one in all those old
Ronald Reagan movies our future couldn't
have been brighter then America was
flushed with victory we were king of the
hill the undisputed leaders in the whole
world
Russia soon got some funny ideas about
that however but believe it or not back
in those innocent days a lot of people
really thought we had a chance to build
a perfect world I wasn't too sure
I graduated from Lehigh but I kept my
mouth shut because I didn't want to
spoil it for the rest of them well a few
things went wrong there were a couple
more Wars there were eight recessions
there was Watergate and a dozen other
man-made disasters along the way but in
spite of all that we did manage to wipe
out a few diseases we put a man on the
moon and we produced more technological
change than all of those who came before
us and I mean combined and we made
America I think a little more just a
little more fair and maybe a little bit
more humane all in all we really haven't
done a bad job and if you believe
everything you read in the papers the
country must be in terrific shape the
stock market just went over 1,300
companies are spending billions of
dollars just buying each other up and
the public is on a buying binge too
they're buying lots of expensive cars
and houses say things are so good even
Chrysler made 2.4 billion dollars last
year and we were broke five years ago
and you
and you how about you well you've got
the world by the tail you're all gonna
make a bundle of money next year at
least some of you will be up ease sooner
than you think we call anybody a yuppie
who's around 40 and makes 40 grand a
year he'll we're hiring some 20 years
old 20 year olds at almost $40,000 33
thousand to start by the way for
engineers to be exact I guess you'd call
them baby yuppies or Guppies or I say
yuppies 20 years ahead of their time but
to be honest with you we're handing you
more than anybody has ever passed on to
their kids generations ahead of you were
lucky if they inherited a little shack
on the back forty you're getting a big
beautiful mansion on a hill that's what
we're leaving you now before you get all
choked up with gratitude I should tell
you one more thing we haven't paid for
all this yet we're leaving in a mansion
all right but it's got a little mortgage
on it about 1.7 trillion dollars in fact
going to two trillion whatever that is
in just a couple of years that's a
public debt we're gonna hand this class
and if you don't like the deal if you
don't want the mansion I'm sorry because
it's yours
along with the note you can't give it
back but you can't get mad about it in
fact I hope you do I'm mad too I think
the mortgage you're picking up is a
national scandal right now we're paying
a hundred and fifty billion dollars a
year in interest alone on our national
debt and adding almost two hundred
billion a year on the principle for a
long time we fought a battle with
inflation in this country we beat it but
we paid a heavy price we paid a price in
unemployment in high interest rates and
in bigger federal deficits and we did
weak in many of our basic industries
especially housing and autos now
inflation is bad enough it's an economic
evil let's hope it stays in its own
little hole but at least inflation is a
penalty we pay now it takes money out of
your pockets every day it's sort of a
page
penalty but these huge deficits are a
penalty that we keep deferring we're
going to leave them for you it's not
pay-as-you-go anymore it's more like
passes of plastic it's a credit card
approach and it's your credit card we're
using what makes this debt so insidious
is that so much of it is invisible I
often say that the government ought to
be forced to follow the truth-in-lending
law every year at tax time it should
have to send out a statement to you just
like your bank does and that statement
would tell every American family where
he or she stands this year for the
average family it would go something
like this dear mr. and mrs. taxpayer
this year your family's share of the
national debt stands at twenty-seven
thousand nine hundred and fifty dollars
in the past twelve months your share is
increased by thirty nine hundred and
eighty dollars your share of the
interest bill this year is twenty one
hundred and twenty seven dollars have a
nice day now maybe you notice that one
line is missing from that statement the
one that says please remit we aren't
remitting we aren't paying our own way
because there are no free lunches in
this life that bill has to be paid some
day and I guess you get the honor and
unless by the way you want to float it
long enough to give it to your kids but
I sure hope you don't I understand you
have something here at MIT called
hacking well somebody is pulling a hack
on your future piling up debt to create
the illusion of prosperity as a cruel
hoax and the joke my young friends is on
you now let me pause you let me ask you
how am i doing so far is anybody mad yet
well if you're not thank you one guy
here if you're not let me go one step
further let me tell you about our second
national scandal one that will put
another dark cloud over your futures I'm
talking about a trade deficit that's
going right off the charts our trade
deficit in goods last year was 123
billion dollars that's 1980 just 48
months ago we had a 40 billion dollar
surplus
so we had a negative swing of 163
billion bucks in less than four years
and we're on a toboggan ride right now
we will probably go a hundred and fifty
billion dollars in the hole this year
alone these two scandals of course are
related by the way the trade imbalance
is a bastard child of those huge
deficits that raise interest rates and
throw the dollar out of whack the high
dollar makes American goods cost more
and give foreign products a big leg up
American companies I'm part of one can
work night and day to get more
productive three years ago we built 10
cars per employee at Chrysler per year
now we build 20 cars per employee per
year but the currency problem just
throws all that effort right out the
window that's one side of the problem
our own fiscal irresponsibility creates
that high dollar and we can't blame
anybody else for it we have to fix that
ourselves but there's another side of
the problem even when we are competitive
we're facing a crazy festival of trade
barriers all over the place that keeps
our products out of other countries
consider Japan last year the Japanese
sold us 37 billion dollars worth of
products more than we sold them
that's a 37 billion dollar deficit with
just one country in one year if you
disregard oil imports 62 percent of our
total grade deficit worldwide comes from
trade with Japan alone now the high
dollar accounts for a lot of that but so
does the fact that Japan protects its
whole markets it does so rather openly
and without much apology Japan is a free
and sovereign nation and it has a right
to act and its own self-interest but
guess what
so do we we've got a right to go to the
Japanese as close friends and trading
partners and say look we got us 37
billion dollar problem here we can't
handle that it has to come down if for
internal political reasons you can't buy
American rice or oranges even though
they're much cheaper than your own
that's ok with us but then you'll have
to cut back on some of the heavy traffic
coming
their way across the Pacific you see
that imbalance isn't just an American
problem
it's Japan's problem too it's a mutual
problem because if it isn't solved soon
your Congress will be forced to take
drastic action the Senate God'll of them
has already fired a shot across their
bow by voting 92 to nothing to retaliate
because of Japan's closed markets now
that's pretty significant when you
consider that Congress can't even get a
unanimous vote to go home for Christmas
so we'll probably see a lot of
finger-pointing for a while and that
could hurt everybody
now consenting adults just shouldn't act
like that we should sit down and reason
this out no threats no talk a trade war
just an absolutely firm understanding
that America has something to protect to
and that we intend to protect it
we intend to protect our ability to
compete but we aren't doing that last
March we took all import restrictions
off of Japanese cars we said to them
look how generous we are now what are
you going to do for us and the Japanese
said thank you very much we're going to
send 24% more cars in this year than we
did last year we got nothing in return
we got some promises well we get a list
of promises every year our guys who go
over to negotiate are supposed to bring
home the bacon for America once in a
while now I don't blame the Japanese for
a minute they are very good businessmen
they are managing their trade according
to the unwritten rules used by almost
every other country in the world and
those rules are simple devise trade
policies that help your own companies
compete we in the other hand are
worshipping at the altar of free trade
we're blindly wedded to a set of lofty
principles that everybody else in the
world ignores we've got this silly
notion that it's a mortal sin to play by
the rules everybody else is using we're
the ones who are out of step today not
the Japanese they're in step with the
rest of the world we're not I always say
we're like those few crazy hockey
players who still refuse to wear their
helmets and we're getting our brains
beat out now don't get me wrong I
believe in free trade who doesn't I
think it's a beautiful ideal it's right
up there with good
and mercy and charity for all but it is
not one of the ten commandments it's not
the way the world works and we aren't
going to change that all by ourselves
maybe someday we'll achieve that ideal I
really hope so but I'm not willing to
risk your futures waiting for that
blessed occasion you see one impact of
these twin scandals may be the
deindustrialization of America in fact
the process is really well underway go
to Pittsburgh or to Akron or Detroit
you'll see it all around you American
heavy industry all smokestack America is
slowly dying many of the companies that
helped build the industrial middle-class
the backbone of the country in this
century are boarded up why they can't
compete anymore they can't compete
because our currency and trade policies
have tilted the international playing
field against them and they're getting
short of breath from running uphill
maybe they could use a breather we got
one at Chrysler six years ago with the
federal loan guarantees and it saved us
I've suggested some kind if you'll
perish ignore the term Industrial Policy
I've suggested some kind of policy to
help other companies in trouble but the
purists say it would wreck free
enterprise forever I don't know why
Chrysler is a bastion of free enterprise
today we're making lots and lots of
money we're paying lots of taxes quarter
billion in 90 days that ain't bad for
guys who were broke 600,000 people have
jobs who would have been on the street
the government never put up a cent and
not only got its 1.2 billion of
guarantees back seven years early but it
made three hundred and fifty million
dollars on the deal to boot pure profit
the Chrysler loan guarantee board wasn't
a welfare office it was a profit Center
they don't have any idea what that means
done in Washington by the way let me be
blunt until we fix the currency problem
and write a trade policy and an
industrial policy for America to compete
it's going to make less and less sense
for companies to build plants and put
people to work in America
our trade deficit has already caused to
three million jobs and more going
overseas every day
the economics when you think of it are
pretty simple you build it in the end
and you sell it in dollars and you don't
need a degree from MIT to figure that
out
hell they probably understand that even
over at Harvard well maybe some of you
right about this point maybe some of you
feel that maybe we should be in dust
realize America get rid of all those
dirty smokestacks and put everybody to
work in service industries or hey maybe
even better high-tech I have to admit
that the weather's nicer in Silicon
Valley than it is in Detroit but let me
tell you if America gives up its
industrial base there is no future for
high-tech either because we smokestack
guys are your best customers for all the
wizardry that comes from Silicon Valley
or from up here on route 28
we put high tech to work we put it to
work in our plans
we've got robots and lazer cameras all
over the joint now we've got some of the
world's finest CAD cam facilities of
course we put it to work every day in
our cars to our new laser in Daytona
sports cars have seven this is
commercial as I get today I have have
seven mini
micro processors or many computers in
each car and unless you put it to work
unless use it to compete high tech is
really just a toy how much do you think
a bag of silicon chips would bring in a
supermarket anyway your future depends
on an America that can hook and jab in
the international marketplace never
forget that and right now we're falling
behind and fast right now America is
getting whipped right now our three
largest exports to Japan you've heard
this before our corn this order soybeans
coal Japan's largest exports dosser cars
trucks video recorders raw materials and
foodstuffs traded for manufactured goods
does a pattern sound a little familiar
it's a classic definition of a colony
that's what deindustrialization and
weak-kneed trade policies are doing to
America
they're making us a colony again we were
a colony once before but we got so mad
we threw the tea into the harbor and not
very far from where I'm standing by the
way well here we are becoming a colony
again and I mean that and I hope it
really makes you mad
so get mad don't burn the place down or
start dumping things into the river here
but get mad get mad because some people
are saying that you're going to be the
first generation of Americans who will
have to settle for less than their
parents had I hope to god you aren't
listening to them I hope you don't
believe that because it does not have to
be true it doesn't have to be true
because even though we've taken our eye
off the ball this is still America and
your birthright as Americans is to
change things in America when people get
mad enough they can change anything
righteous anger intelligently directed
has made this the greatest democracy in
the world I hope every cancer researcher
in the country goes to work every
morning mad and every engineer and
economist even and teacher and
Congressman satisfied people change
nothing only angry people change things
I got mad six years ago really mad when
the Wall Street Journal said a little
prayer over Chrysler in one of their
editorials and told us in big bold type
please die with dignity a lot of people
that Chrysler got mad as hell at that
kind of advice they got so mad they
scratched and they clawed and they
survived so you get mad to get mad at
the people in Washington who are burying
you under a dung heap of public debt
tell them no more get mad at the free
lunches of the world and tell them no
more it's time for sacrifice get mad at
the ideologues who want to make you
martyrs to some eighteenth century trade
principals who want you to live in a
colony tell them no more we want to
compete and get mad at anybody who tells
you that you have to settle for less
tell them get the hell out of my way you
owe that to yourselves your education is
as good as anybody can get
anywhere remember that you're smart
enough to compete with anybody in the
world
and you deserve the chance to be the
best you're to yourselves and to those
who follow you to now you're not getting
a perfect world but I hope you all
appreciate what has been given to you I
hope you feel a deep appreciation for
what other people have done so that you
could be here today but I also hope you
understand how you pay that debt it
doesn't get paid to me or my generation
or to your teachers or even to your
parents
you know there's a scene in the movie a
guess who's coming to dinner
a father is very angry with his son and
he says I carried that mailbag for 40
years so you could go to college into
Medical School
you owe me for that and the son says hey
I owe you nothing if you carried that
mailbag a million miles you did what you
were supposed to do you owed me
everything you could ever do for me just
as I will owe my kids the Sun wasn't
ungrateful he loved and respected his
father but he also understood our
civilization is supposed to work one
generation making things a little better
for the next fathers and mothers
sacrificing everything for their kids
that's how we got where we are today
that's the way civilization is supposed
to work now my generation is leaving you
with too much debt and we're a little
blind to some of the new economic
realities in the world we're leaving
with a lot of problems to solve big deal
but that's the way civilization works to
every generation inherits the
unfulfilled dreams of the one that came
before it and every generation inherits
its own set of challenges
we were naive 40 years ago thinking we
had a shot at making a perfect world but
in many ways we made it a lot better for
you and by the way we're not through yet
almost but not yet you more than most
have been given the tools to meet your
own set of challenges a degree from MIT
just about guarantees you at least a
shot at molding the future
it's a prestigious ticket and it puts
you right up in front of the pack but
let me tell you may also be a bit of a
burden to you people are gonna expect
more of you they're expecting you to be
leaders and to be winners your MIT
degree puts you in the pole position as
they say and the green flag is about to
go up so now let's see if you're mad
enough to make this imperfect world just
a little better for your kids let's see
what you're made of so class of 85 start
your engines
[Applause]